Ted Cruz appeared on the Laura Ingraham
show on Fox news last night and this is
if you were to look up projection in the
dictionary it should have an interactive
uh video clip of of Ted Cruz's
appearance on Fox news last night so let
me set this up for you one of the
phenomena that we've noticed with
Republicans over the last five or six
years is whenever they really start
harping on Democrats are doing X or
Democrats will do X we need to very
seriously look at whether what they mean
is we are doing this or we plan to do
this and I'll give you some examples
Donald Trump and I know many of you have
heard this Donald Trump said so many
times we can't vote for Hillary in 2016
because she can't be trusted with her
email she's using personal email she
can't be trusted with classified and
secret information and on and on and it
really didn't make sense and it was
actually Trump who planned to do all of
those very things Trump completely
untrustworthy with secret information
from allies spilling secrets from allies
to a Russian spy recruiter in the Oval
Office many in Trump's Inner Circle
including Mark Meadows Ivanka Trump
Jared Kushner using private email while
they were working for Donald Trump trump
eating notes that are supposed to be
preserved as records Trump power
flushing 10 to 15 times notes that are
supposed to be kept for presidential
records so when he starts talking when
they start talking about the left is
going to do this thing we should be like
are they actually doing it and often the
answer is yes for six months Trump's
saying they're gonna do fraud in the
2020 election we can't do vote by mail
they're going to win and they're going
to steal it and all this different stuff
and of course it was Trump and his
acolytes who filed 60 frivolous legal
complaints insisted that vans and
machines and all these different things
mean that they actually had the election
stolen from them they were the ones
trying to steal the election so now with
that context in mind listen to what with
a straight face Ted Cruz says last night
on Fox News
he has no shame listen very closely you
cannot accept it as a result they know
they're going to lose
and Nancy Pelosi is not going to go
quietly she's going to scream she's
already preparing to scream the election
was stolen and by the way what she means
by stolen is people showed up to vote
against Democrats that that's what's
stealing the election is and remember
Democrats don't believe in democracy
this how can he say this with a straight
face this is exactly what they did in
2020 when they said in 2020 it was
stolen
what it was was that more Democrats came
out to vote that's that's what happened
when they say Nancy Pelosi is planning
to claim it was stolen no that's what
you guys did and that's exactly what
they're going to do again depending on
the results in November here's a bonus
uh Ted Cruz clip here
uh where he complains he hasn't spoken
with Joe Biden personally and that
that's like a problem in some way you
know the question
every day somebody says who's really
running things and let me tell you the
scary thing I have no idea so Biden's
been president what 15 months in that
entire time I have not spoken with him
once and that's true of almost every
Republican senator I gotta say that's
weird why does Biden have to speak to
them to show he's really the president
why would Biden speak to Ted Cruz Ted
Cruz is out of his mind and this is a
really new common thing on the right
Kyle Rittenhouse has also been pulling
this clearly Joe Biden is doing
something wrong because he hasn't met
with Kyle Rittenhouse he's like why
would Biden meet with Kyle Rittenhouse
or you know is is calling you out on
Twitter uh what would you like them to
know most about your story right
[Music]
[Music]
watching curiosity stream at home for
over a year now really no better place
to find the newest and best
documentaries curiosity stream selection
is way better than any other platform I
recently watched the documentary Return
of the Buffalo a fascinating animal and
fascinating things to know about
conservation of the Buffalo as well
curiosity stream adds new titles every
month you're never going to run out of
great documentary content you can learn
something new zone out on a nature
documentary whatever you're looking for
they have it if you love documentaries
you are missing out if you don't have
curiosity stream it's super affordable
curiosity stream is giving my audience
25 off which means you can get it for 15
bucks a year go to curiositystream.com
Pacman the link is underneath this video